la parole est maintenant président bruno
retailleau pour le groupe l'est
républicain pendant deux minutes
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre dimanche dernier ce 18 octobre
la chancelière allemande était à
istanbul elle a rencontré le président
erdogan qui a fait monter les enchères
puisque elle lui a mis en quelque sorte
un marché en main oui la turquie
acceptent de coopérer sur la question
des réfugiés
mais en contrepartie la turquie exige
une accélération dans le processus de
négociations qui devraient aboutir à
l'adhésion de ce pays à l'union
européenne
madame angela merkel a répondu qu'elle
accepterait de plaider favorablement
pour l'ouverture de nouveaux chapitres
sur la politique économique et monétaire
sur les chapitres notamment relatifs à
la sécurité à la liberté comme s'il
n'existait pas de question dans ce pays
vis-à-vis de ces sujets est le problème
le problème c'est que nous retrouvons la
trace dans la conclusion le 15 octobre
dernier jeudi dernier les conclusions du
conseil européen de cette phrase qui
était aussi admise est votée par la
france
le processus d'adhésion de la turquie
doit être relancé monsieur le premier
ministre
le marchandage de monsieur erdogan est
inadmissible il l'est d'autant plus
quand on connaît la terrible ambiguïté
d'ankara vis-à-vis de la lutte du combat
contre l'islamisme radical
monsieur erdogan est plus préoccupé par
la question kurde que par la lutte
contre daraîche ma question est simple
elle demande et j'espère que vous y
ferez une réponse très claire le droit
de la france et là est ce que oui ou non
la france acceptera de dire oui à ces
nouvelles exigences en vue de l'adhésion
de la turquie à l'union européenne
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre c'est le
président monsieur président retailleau
j'ai répondu il ya un instant à
l'assemblée nationale et à françois
fillon et je le fais bien volontiers
aussi ici au sénat logiquement
normalement un président de groupe sur
des sujets qui sont en effet lourds et
graves
la turquie d'un partenaire stratégique
de la france et de l'union européenne
pas depuis quelques mois allié au sein
de l'alliance atlantique de l'otan''
depuis 1952
engagé dans un processus de
rapprochement avec l'union européenne et
qui se trouve aujourd'hui plus que
jamais au carrefour d'enjeux
stratégiques majeures elle est elle doit
être
même si parfois elle doit clarifier ses
objectifs vous venez de le rappeler elle
est un allié pour parvenir à une
solution politique en syrie peut pas
vouloir faire en sorte que les grandes
puissances russie etats unis les pays
importants dans la région voisin de la
syrie iran turquie des pays du golfe
participe d'une solution et ne pas
chercher une solution avec la turquie
même si nous ignorons rien d'un certain
nombre d'objectifs
la turquie est soumise à d'importantes
pressions
je pense bien sûr à la pression des
réfugiés
plus de deux millions de syriens qui se
trouve aujourd'hui en turquie et si nous
n'aidons pas la turquie
si nous les non pas par ailleurs le
liban et la jordanie
ce défi sera encore plus difficile à
maîtriser et à traiter en europe
l'intérêt de l'union européenne
l'intérêt de la france c'est de bâtir
des solutions avec la turquie
et puis la turquie est aussi la cible
d'attentats celui d'ankara on est
malheureusement une terrible
démonstration le contexte politique de
la turquie est sensible
approche des élections législatives qui
ont lieu le 1er novembre
même si aucun d'entre nous ne méconnaît
le contexte les débats qui ont cours au
sein de la société turque et notre
intérêt est de poursuivre le dialogue
engagé depuis plusieurs années
maintenant est de soutenir dans l'effort
incontestable que la turquie fournit
depuis plusieurs mois depuis plusieurs
années pour l'accueil des réfugiés
syriens c'est pourquoi le conseil
européen du 15 octobre a décidé la mise
en place d'un plan d'action entre
l'union européenne et la turquie afin de
renforcer notre coopération pour
garantir des conditions de vie dignes et
humaine aux réfugiés qui sont accueillis
sur le sol turc de lutter contre les
réseaux de passeurs vers l'europe vers
la grèce notamment et de renforcer bien
sûr le contrôle de nos frontières
extérieures et l'union européenne
parallèlement c'est la décision qui a
été prise apportera également un soutien
financier accru à la turquie avec à la
fois de l'aide humanitaire et les fonds
qui doivent permettre d'appuyer
l'hébergement l'insertion la formation
des réfugiés cet engagement de l'europe
est indispensable et il ne modifie pas
en même temps notre position vis-à-vis
de la turquie pour avancer sur des
dossiers comme ceux de la libéralisation
des visas ou le processus de
négociations d'adhésion en tant que pays
candidat
la turquie est engagé dans une
négociation selon des règles qu'elle a
elle-même accepter qu'ils ne peuvent pas
être modifiées nous souhaitons c'est la
position de la france que ces
négociations avancent dans les domaines
sur lesquels la turquie est prête et je
n'ai déjà rappelé tout à l'heure à
françois fillon
comme vous le savez quatorze chapitres
sur 35 ont été ouverts un a été fermé un
seul chapitre à d'ailleurs été ouverte
depuis 2000 13 11 l'ont été pendant la
présidence de nicolas sarkozy
la question de l'adhésion turque reste
une perspective de très long terme qui
le moment venu vous le savez sera
tranchée par le peuple français
faisons donc attention monsieur le
président si vous me permettez cette
phrase
conclusion à deux choses la première
c'est le respect de ce grand pays qu'est
la turquie ce qui nous empêche pas
d'être lucide sur ce qui peut s'y passer
mais soyons attentifs à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans la région et d'ailleurs
l'une des forces de la france c'est
d'être capable de parler avec tous aussi
bien avec les jordaniens j'étais il ya
quelques jours dans ce pays qui a besoin
de notre soutien nous accueillons le
président de l'iran au mois de novembre
le président la république a évoqué
évidemment la situation dans cette
région avec le président poutine et nous
discutons bien sûr comme d'autres avec
la turquie c'est la force de la france
donne être aligné sur personne et
d'avoir la même parole et la même
cohérence avec chacun de ses
interlocuteurs et le deuxième je n'ai
pas ressenti ça je le reconnais dans
votre question en tout cas de manière
moins forte que tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée nationale c'est attention
aussi à notre lien notre solidarité avec
l'allemagne dans ces moments là même si
nous avons eu notre position l'allemagne
à la sienne l'allemagne fait face à un
défi considérable qui est celui de
l'accueil des réfugiés et il me paraît
en tout cas c'est la position du
gouvernement français et je les exprime
que dans ces moments là la solidarité
entre la france et l'allemagne de jouer
à plein et nous devons ensemble avancé
pour l'union européenne aussi face aux
défis considérables qui se posent pas
l'union européenne et sans la solidarité
entre la france et l'allemagne
il ne peut pas y avoir de solution sur
le président recueille au bon 20
secondes
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre
la solidarité ne signifie pas
l'aveuglément y compris vis-à-vis de
notre partenaire principal qu'est
l'allemagne le respect signifie aussi la
vérité que l'on doit à ce grand peuple
à ce grand pays qu'est la turquie je
crois que nous commettons une double
faute
une faute vis-à-vis de nos partenaires
turcs en leur laissant miroiter un jour
une adhésion une faute vis-à-vis du
projet européen tout simplement parce
que la turquie n'est européenne lui dans
sa géographie ni dans ceux d'histoire ni
dans sa civilisation
oui à une coopération renforcée non à
une adhésion future
eh bien merci monsieur le premier
ministre vous vouliez dire un mot c'est
vraiment mon horloge à moi oui merci
monsieur le président mais cette
constitution de la vème république est
formidable elle permet de répondre au
président un mot seulement un mot nous
alignement ce l'allemagne jamais
solidarité totalement sur tous les
sujets défense diplomatiques mais aussi
économiques
seul et souvent dans vos bancs qu'on
nous a rappelé l'exemple allemand nous
ne sommes alignés sur personne et sur la
turquie sur la turquie sans rien y
connaître sans aucun aveuglement avec la
plus grande lucidité mais c'est vrai
avec tous les pays de la région
attention aux mots que nous prononçons
civilisation attention aux mots que nous
prononçons ça n'est pas un combat que
nous pouvons engager de civilisation il
ya un combat qui est celui des
civilisations et je les ai déjà dit
contre le terrorisme et la barbarie
mais avec la turquie comme avec deux
pays nous devons être capables sur nos
valeurs et sur des valeurs qui sont
universelles de bâtir des partenariats
car sinon monsieur retailleau attention
à la confrontation
nous ne pouvons pas accepter cette
confrontation